competition where a professional chef
and a mom cook head-to-head preparing
the best dishes possible
featuring one secret ingredient first
competitors today is lenay Brodie
I'm Lynnae Brodie and I'm long - a 23
month old son named ace since I've
become a mom my son takes naps during
the day and I have turned to watching
lots of cooking show so it's fun to
experiment and sometimes he likes them
and sometimes he hates them
the last Thanksgiving we had I cooked a
few Thanksgiving dishes and people were
really impressed so I think it kind of
put me as a legitimate contender in my
family to actually be a cook so winning
this competition with this further
nitrogen mercy for my family in the
kitchen and competing against lenay is
professional chef Anthony Karen I'm chef
Anthony Karen I'm was chef founder and
one of the owners of 800 degrees
Neapolitan pizzeria I've been a chef for
20 years I grew up cooking for my family
ever since the age of about 5 and when I
was in college got a job in a local
diner and since that time like I just
fell in love with cooking I've never
looked back I think that the strategy is
to go with relatively simple flavors but
to use some technique that's got some
wow
winning mom versus chef to me would be
some bragging rights because my best
friend has been on mom versus chef as
the chef and he lost welcome Ellen a
welcome chef today you're going to be
competing to see who can create the
tastiest dish featuring one secret
ingredient let me introduce you to our
panel judges smiley and I'm 8 years old
my favorite food is watermelon my name
is Stella I am 9 years old and my
favorite food is spaghetti tacos your
final judge is me I'm Andrew from 25
years old and my favorite food is
Brussels sprouts chefs are you ready to
find out what today's secret ingredient
is
whenever you cook today has to feature
it I can't promise it will be easy
Sylla will you do the honors whoo chefs
today your secret in green is
cauliflower you guys like cauliflower I
don't like cauliflower because it smells
like old nasty parts you have a favorite
vegetable yeah what about you I like
wine when a dear kids like cauliflower
don't think I've
forgiving my kid cauliflower it's not my
favorite vegetable well honestly I think
it's a little bit of a boring flavor to
make it more interesting we're gonna
focus on adding some flavor to it
chef's you have 30 minutes to cook your
food all the time stat now I have zero
experience DQ and cauliflower I don't
even know if I know how to properly cut
it I have used a food processor before
today I'm gonna be cooking a goat cheese
cauliflower fried ball kids love fried
food and I feel like when you're a mom
you'll do anything to get your kids eat
their vegetables I've worked with
cauliflower a lot over the 20 years very
versatile vegetable so I'm gonna make a
cauliflower souffle it'll puff up nicely
in the oven and then when we bring it to
the table will poke a hole on the top
and pour in some cheddar cheese sauce
I'm starting to do everything that I
need to do and again learning I'm
teaching myself how to properly chop it
trying to get all the green on and I'm
going to throw it into the food
processor and pulse it just to make sure
that there's no chunky pieces left
I need to get this cauliflower steamed
right away the steaming process is going
to take a while now that I've got the
cauliflower in the steamer I can focus
on the souffle base a classic French
patty shoe made with roux
so flour and butter and then milk I am
adding some sea salt Lac Kepper oregano
and dried parsley because I just always
cook with those at home so I'm stirring
the pot and I'm realizing that the
burner doesn't feel super hot so I just
decided pump it all the way up and I'm
really hoping it doesn't burn because I
think that will completely ruin my dish
chef's you have 15 minutes keep on
cooking 15 minutes I am taking my
steamed cauliflower which is now nice
and tender processing that down to a
smooth puree so now I've got my souffle
base has come together we've beat the
PATA choux the corn and the cauliflower
together and we're going to start to
fold in the egg whites I noticed that
one of the judges Miley said that her
favorite vegetable was corn so we
decided to throw some of that in there
to hopefully maybe buy a boat so now I'm
taking our souffle molds and I'm
buttering them with soft butter I'm
filling each one with the souffle and
egg white based mixture
in this other bowl I'm going to mix
about 3/4 of a cup and a tablespoon of
flour 1 egg garlic and the juice of a
fresh lemon you a goal of what they're
cooking yeah let's go look you guys
check on chef Anthony and I'll go see
what Lynnae is doing so a lot you ever
heard of a choc Allah souffle yeah kind
of like that but it's not gonna be sweet
it's gonna be savory or salty okay it's
not like was it like cauliflower and
corn good I thought you're in a safe
heart sandwich it's got eggs in it so
it's no surprise Thank You chef oh
you're welcome yeah I hope you like it
hey Lenny hi so what's your strategy
trying to get their kids to eat okay
I've hidden it with a lot of goat cheese
which is nice creamy honey to make it a
little bit sweet so what is your
strategy in terms of getting me to like
this I feel like goat cheese is the best
ingredient not everybody likes goat
cheese I have yet to meet someone
another like goat cheese good luck with
the rest of your cooking Thank You chefs
you have five minutes remaining
good got everything working I'm gonna go
check my souffle but we're just gonna
get these plates ready first I'm now
going to take an ice cream scooper and
scoop some of this mixture into this hot
pan of no oils I flip them after two
minutes on each side and then I put them
on the plate I'm going to turn my
attention to the cheese sauce when I
present the dish after the souffle is
has fully baked and risen out of the
souffle mold I'm going to poke a hole in
the top of the souffle and pour in the
cheddar cheese sauce I crumble some goat
cheese on top and drizzle some honey as
well hi chefs your time is up stop
working honey can you please describe
your dish so that is a cauliflower and
goat cheese fritter so what I did is I
post the cauliflower in a food processor
I did a dry fry for about 15 minutes let
that cool off and then threw it in the
mixture and then we deep-fried them it's
like salty and sweet and I really like
the honey can't really taste cauliflower
at all which I guess that's good right
I like a crunchy I think it gives her
like a little bit more taste to all of
it it does not taste like cauliflower
tastes like pancakes I wouldn't want my
mom to make this it reminds me of like a
Greek cheese pie it's really tasty
thank you a we're ready to try chef
Anthony's food watch out this is very
hot so don't touch the ceramic
cauliflower souffle pureed cauliflower
to the PATA choux folded egg whites to
give the souffle it's lifting loft now
we're gonna just take a little hole and
pour in some cheese sauce he tastes the
cauliflower in this really I like fluffy
things and I also really love corn and
cheese the cheese sauce is really
amazing I used to eat these chicken pot
pies these microwavable chicken pot pies
as a kid and this is like the best
version of that but with cheese poured
on top and the melted cheese reminds me
of mac and cheese I think every kid
loves mac and cheese when every kid my
sister doesn't you know how sisters are
annoying thanks chef Anthony chefs thank
you for preparing some delicious food
for us all right thank you you guys
could take a break while we decide all
the tastiest dish how did you think you
did
you got one pretty Wow about you yeah I
was pretty happy with it
I liked your dish a lot I thought you
know with the crispy fritter thing the
kids are gonna love that
your cheese sauce looked really
incredible thank you yeah hopefully the
hopefully the souffle wasn't over their
heads a great job yeah you thought your
dish was amazing so best of luck and
yeah tough competition
I know good luck see who wins yeah I
think Linda had a really great dish cuz
I really liked the texture and the
sweetness of her dish like everyone for
lunch it is packed up in a box and like
it is a falling like that they were both
very tasty chef Anthony's kind of
together I think I like the way his
tasted more and and it was really fun to
eat I liked that it was really like
puffy it felt like I was eating a
cupcake I think another one let's bring
up the chef's welcome back chefs we
decided on the winner so you both cooked
some amazing dishes today unfortunately
we can only have one winner chef Anthony
we think your dish was very tasty but we
think that Chef Renee's dish was more
tasty sir chef one day you've won Mon
versus chef thank you now coming into it
I didn't think I was going to be able to
beat a chef but I did it I can't wait to
tell my family that I won and make this
for them and show them what a great cook
I actually can be thank you
obviously I was a little disappointed
that I did not win mom versus chef I was
really hoping for some bragging rights
as my best friend as a chef who's also
appeared on mom versus chef and he lost
to thank you both for coming and cooking
for us today you both prepared some
amazing dishes well our secret
ingredient be next episode well what do
you guys want it to be nice maybe rice
this has been mom versus chef oh yes